you were talking about the coconut oil and switching that in your mouth. I thought it's
if you had like some silver filling that wasn't such a great idea. Did I misunderstand that
in the past? No, so you're right. So I did I didn't bring that piece up. I don't know,
you're to remember, David, if you have silver fillings in your mouth, but you can still,
so if you do have silver fillings in your mouth, you do not want to do oil pulling.
That's what you do. Okay. I do that. Yeah. Oil pulling is putting a tablespoon of coconut oil
in your mouth and swashing it on your mouth for 10 to 15 minutes and then spinning it on
the sink to hopefully pull the workery and other metals out of your gums and through the
buckle mucosa of your cheeks. But you can't do that if you have metal in your mouth. So if you do
have metal in your mouth, yeah, maybe you shouldn't swish it around your whole mouth, but just try
to lubricate its mouth a little bit. Not trying to pull metals. So you would put a tablespoon of coconut
oil in your mouth. It'd be hard for us to keep it in your mouth for more than a minute or so anyhow.
Yeah. Thank you for clarifying. I get it.